hello believe nation welcome to another
edition of the Evan Carmichael show this
show is all about helping you build your
business up taking that dream that you
have and make it into a success I'm
excited today today I'm doing another
mailbag episode I'm gonna be talking
about setting routines for your business
how much to pay for rent what I would do
if I at the start over from scratch and
should you start a business on a loan or
not I just want to get to your calls
talking to use is my favorite part of
the show all right so I got a question
from one of my loyal neutral newsletter
subscribers Colin who wrote in to say do
you have any routine advice for the
nocturnal now I'm a big believer in
setting up routines I'm a huge fan
because as entrepreneurs you can find
that one day you're on top of the world
you're killing your goals you're out
there hitting it hard and then the next
day you're up and you're you're you're
sluggish and slow and you don't know
where all that energy went and then you
know maybe you watch a seminar or maybe
you call into a radio show or maybe you
have this great meeting and that gets
you energized again and believing in
yourself and then you're on fire but
that may not happen until 2:00 in the
afternoon or 9:00 at night and then you
don't have a lot of time left in the day
so I'm a huge fan of starting off the
day with the routine that sets you up
for success that gets you motivated and
energized and wanting to go out there
and and kill it today for your business
so Coloradans say do you have advice for
the nocturnal because my advice was for
morning routines so Colin this is a
fantastic question and I'm just a big
believer in whenever you wake up whether
it's whether you're starting your day at
noon because because you're staying up
till 4:00 in the morning or you're
starting your day at 6:00 in the morning
setting that routine from the starts
there are a few key elements that I'm a
huge fan of one is gratitude but can I
start the day with gratitude and if
you're waking up at noon start your day
with gratitude and you know that that
could be something as simple as you know
writing down I have a little pad next to
my desk and I write down when I wake up
three things that I'm grateful for and I
also send a quick text to my wife with a
little cartoon happy face or something
just just to say that that I'm thinking
of her because she's out the door before
me
and start under the gratitude and love
may sound cheesy may sound hokey may
sound like a not not a practical
business strategy but it really helps it
helps the day you know if you're
starting the day with gratitude and love
it just puts you in the right framework
to be able to go out and achieve massive
success with your business the next
thing is music
I gotta have music put music on that
gets you moving that gets you bumping
that gets your head bouncing around it's
so important because music can instantly
change your state you may be in a state
of being depressed and down on yourself
and and lacking in confidence and you
put a song on and it gets you all
energized and ready to go so again this
applies whether you are a morning person
and you're waking up with 6:00 a.m. when
you're starting to go and kill it or if
you're a nocturnal person and you're
waking up at noon start with the same
strategies the third biggest one is
remember you're wise why are you doing
this why is it so important to you
there's a big wine a little wide the big
why is that big overarching huge goal
that you have this big mission you want
to go and accomplish and the little
why's are the kind of day-to-day things
that that that customers are giving you
feedback saying you helped change my
life saying thank you so much when you
get that positive recognition and
reinforcement it helps make you want to
keep going it helps you continue to
believe in yourself and so having that
routine even if you're a nocturnal
person know if you're waking up at noon
and you're working till 4:00 in the
morning don't get your day started at
8:00 at night because you get energized
right start at noon start with gratitude
start with music start by remembering
you're wise start by setting up a
routine for yourself that gets you
energized and motivated and wanting to
start the day and go out and kill it
I wanna get to the calls I have Denise
on the line Denise where are you family
how can I help I'm in Lake Oswego Oregon
and I've been talking to you for a
couple of months about juggling my
for-profit my nonprofit entity and the
nonprofit snagged a big deal a
television deal to do a show about our
nonprofit and I don't have a clue how to
set up the deal so that we serve the
nonprofit but me and my partner Dan
bleeding money on this for 20 years we
want to a fair deal and a percentage
instead of just a salary but
any suggestions on how we set this up
what's a fair percentage for the
nonprofit what should we take there's
going to be a lot of money because
they're going to take it to network
television but I want to set up the deal
right now
so there they're doing a deal about the
nonprofit yep and it's gonna be a
television show exclusively about the
the nonprofit so how do we pay ourselves
back for all the money that we poured
into the for-profit a non-profit trying
to get something to happen
how do your profit and nonprofit work
together not really I've just been
juggling two causes so I set one up as a
for-profit and I set one up as a
non-profit and I'm committed to both and
invested in both now the nonprofit
snagged a big deal but I have partners
and bills to pay in the for-profit front
this is what I keep calling you about
how do i how do i cross that bridge and
share the money with everybody even
though part of its of for-profit
entities do you take a salary from the
nonprofit there's been no money to take
a salary from anywhere I've been
bleeding money for both of these for
years now the nonprofit has a big deal
on the table yeah so why not take a
salary from it why not take some money
from it I want to I but I want more than
a salary I have a sweat equity partners
to pay back so I can't I don't feel good
about just paying myself I want to pull
some money to pay off prior you know
equity debt in the in the profit or the
nonprofit well right now the only thing
attracting money is the nonprofit so
where I'm trying to keep both of them
going forward but you can't really pull
money out of a non-profit to pay off
your for-profit debt yeah no you can't
that's that's not that's not really
legit especially if they're not related
right I mean there's nothing wrong with
you getting paid to run the nonprofit
you you deserve that you're putting a
lot of love into it it's been years of
sacrifice and and you went out and got
this great deal and that's amazing and
so there's nothing wrong with you being
paid if you look at any nonprofit you
look at the CEOs you look at the
there's they're getting paid to run
those organizations it's not like you're
taking millions and millions of dollars
out but you need to get paid to be able
to continue living but pulling money out
to support partners in a for-profit
business that has nothing to do with
your nonprofit is is really sketchy you
know if you're gonna have people
eventually donate into your non
nonprofit that's going to cause a lot of
concern so I just have to be okay with I
get a salary right now cuz it's taking
off and the for-profit part partners
have to ride with me until we have a
profit I would try to think of is there
a way that you can use the exposure from
from the TV show to then potentially
also help your for-profit company out
you know if you if you become I don't
know if you walk do watch Shark Tank yes
all of those five main investors they
get paid to be on that show but they
make a lot of deals and money afterwards
they get book deals their companies get
a lot of exposure and so if your your
your TV show may not be shark tank level
yet you know you could work towards that
but if you're getting a lot of exposure
and you're on camera and they're
showcasing everything that you guys are
doing that raises your profile which can
help your for-profit business right
right and and they're interested in
doing the shell on the for-profit
business so I believe you know a year
from now there won't be flush
but it's this interim where I've got
money and my other partners don't and I
can't really support all of them out of
what I get so I'm just I'm feeling like
it's not fair for me to have this yet
this beautiful income yet and I've got
to get passed back yeah yeah it's
another limiting belief you know it's uh
you deserve it you did a lot of work to
get this nonprofit up up and running and
it has nothing to do with those partners
in the other business you know they were
helping you with the nonprofit then they
deserve a salary as well for helping get
this this show off the ground but you
know they they shouldn't be necessarily
jealous of the what you're doing and
there could be an opportunity there for
you to take the successful TV show you
know with the nonprofit and turn that
into
the TV show with the for profit and
that's the way that the your partners
can get get paid back as well
I love that you have a sense of you want
to do the right thing
you want your partners to get paid off
you're not just you know in this for
yourself and and you feel a sense of
obligation to others which is a amazing
quality in an entrepreneur because a lot
of people don't necessarily have that
and they're just in it for themselves
but the the you know the flipside of
going taking that too far is not having
enough self-worth and feeling like you
deserve this right like yes a non-profit
can be run like a business and can make
money and yes as the owner and the
founder you deserve to get paid for
bringing success to the nonprofit right
so you deserve that we've done a lot of
work you're helping a lot of people and
you should feel proud thank you thank
you your life always changes things all
right Denise good luck and keep me
posted I'm here every two weeks I think
okay all right take care
yeah and for everybody listening it's
awesome to have a conscience I believe
you need to have a conscience it's a
conscious to your partner's a conscious
to your customers are conscious to to
anybody who's involved in your
organization but you also have to think
of yourself you also have to have
self-worth you know you deserve to get
paid for what you're doing and if one
business isn't working out you know
you're gonna try your best to make that
work but you shouldn't be sacrificing
something from another business to go
help your your business that's
struggling so have some self-confidence
know that what you're doing is is
valuable and you deserve to get paid for
what you're doing next up in the mailbag
is a question from one of my YouTube
viewers Sally who wrote in to say I
don't have money would it be a bad idea
to get a loan to start my own business
this is a huge question and one that so
many entrepreneurs face as they're
trying to launch their business right
you don't have enough capital to start
what do you do my answer yes it is a bad
idea that started a business on alone
I'm a huge believer in that you should
not be spending money until you're
making money because everybody can spend
money it's easy to spend money right if
I give you a 100
you could find a hundred thousand
different ways to do it anybody can
spend money the hard part is to earn
money and if you go out and just start a
business with no background and no
financing you're probably gonna fail
right most businesses will fail right 80
percent of business in America fail in
five years that's probably going to be
you those are the numbers so how do you
avoid that you avoid it by not going out
and taking a loan because you might be
in debt for the rest of your life paying
this off you're gonna make mistakes
you're gonna go with the wrong product
to service it won't be perfect you you
won't have the right marketing strategy
you won't have the right pricing
strategy you won't have the right
partnerships and alliances set up
there's gonna be so many mistakes that
you're gonna make that that could sink
your business and leave you in a huge
hole with debt so that's that's the
negative so what do you do how do you
get out of that instead I recommend
going out and actually modeling success
so find a company that you love I don't
know what industry you're in but find a
company that you look up to that has ten
employees or less and entrepreneurs say
I want to be like that person and go
work for them go get a job working for
them if you're getting the job it
shouldn't be just to give you a paycheck
it should be to help you learn and
understand how an industry works instead
of paying to go take a class or go to
university or take this training course
you're getting paid to learn about the
business you're getting paid to make
mistakes you're getting paid to make
contacts it's so important and then when
you're ready to go on launch your own
business you already have a lot of your
ducks lined up so find that company
offer to work for them and then get as
close to the entrepreneur founder as
possible okay don't just do what you're
hired to do you want to go in and get as
close to the founder as possible take
out as many projects as you can know as
much about the business as possible give
yourself as much exposure and training
because that's gonna set you up for
success when you go and launch your own
company there aren't too many
entrepreneurs in the world who will say
yeah I don't need any extra help you
know we're good we're fine you know
I'm I'm I have all this work but we
don't need people to help us out right
if you're if you're a dedicated employee
and you're taking on extra work and it's
not about getting paid to do it right
you can get us ours you do it and that's
fine but take on extra work weekends
evenings volunteer right the whole point
of this is you're learning about the
business and the entrepreneur founder
will want to help right if they see
dedicated employees who are trying to
learn about the business and provide
value back then then they're going to
give you more responsibility the second
thing that that does is it also teaches
you if you like the business a lot a lot
of people will start a company and
they're you know you look at it from the
outside and say wow that's such a cool
idea I could make a lot of money there I
could have a big impact there and then
they get into it and they realized you
know what this isn't for me you know it
was maybe more of a hobby or just an
idea but I'm not I'm not a huge fan of
doing this if you've taken out a loan
and started this business you're out of
luck right that's a huge problem that
you've just run into where if you go
work for somebody else and you look at
that entrepreneur and you get decide do
I want to be like that person do I want
that person's lifestyle am I actually
enjoying the work I'm doing or was it a
case of just the grass looking green on
the other side so go get that job to
learn from somebody at the same time you
start part-time find a low-cost easy way
to get started where you're not
investing a lot of a lot of money just
to get your feet wet just understand how
your customers work even if it's free or
even aside at cost again I don't know
what your business is but you want to
just build up momentum build up
experience build up a database of
customers build yourself up so that when
you are ready to go and launch full-time
one you've got the experience and
working at the job and two you have the
experience I'm working with some
customers understanding what they like
what they want what they're buying and
having people to be able to settle - for
when you launch it's way less risky and
way smarter than just jumping on land
cashing in your retirement savings or
taking out a loan to launch that
business okay it's so important because
again so many companies fail and I don't
want that to be you I want to share an
example that I think
help you there's a vegan bakery here in
Toronto called bunner's and it's a new
bakery and it was started by an arch
Burnham Ashley and I first met Ashley in
the basement of a church the church was
having a bake sale and she was there
selling her gluten-free butter tarts and
I was taking gluten free butter tarts I
gotta try these he's sound amazing and
so I went to go see her and a lot of
people when they're first starting a
bakery they they want to they want to
have a bake shop right they want to
invest in the kitchen they want to
invest in a retail storefront that costs
a lot of money and she could have gone
out and taken out a loan and tried to
launch it up but she probably would have
made a ton of mistakes and would have
failed so she started the smart way she
started on evenings on weekends in
church basements and bake sales and she
learned what recipes did well what
people wanted to buy she learned she'd
learned how to build a list of customers
who could then continue to repeat and
buy from her she learned how to improve
the process of making her cupcakes and
her muffins and her butter tarts she
learned and then as she gained customers
and as she started making money she then
opened up her first location and it was
a big success she had her first location
that did well then she'll whether per
second locations which has got two now
then she loaded a cookbook she sells
wholesale she's won all sorts of awards
for the best new Bake Shop best dessert
shop having the best muffin in the City
of Toronto and that's not even vegan
it's not best vegan dessert shop it's
best dessert shop best new Bake Shop in
the city because she gained a lot of
experience starting part-time starting
evenings and weekends starting to learn
the model learn the market learn the
customers so don't start your business
on a loan please don't start a business
by cashing in your retirement savings
it's so risky your chances of failure go
up dramatically because you're gonna
make so many mistakes instead go learn
from somebody who's done it go learn
from them get the experience get the
track record get some connections make
your mistakes while getting paid and
then start part-time find an easy
low-cost cheap way to get started
making mistakes early that's not cost
you a lot of money and slowly build up
to the point when when you do launch
full-time you're gonna be a huge success
next question up is from tor who wrote
in to say if you were starting your
business all over again from scratch
with the knowledge you have now but no
one knew who you were how would you
start getting organic traffic to your
website and start branding yourself this
is a great question and I think about it
a lot I often think about if I was
starting up again how would I how when I
kicked my own butt what would I be doing
differently and my number one strategy
would be I would be all in on YouTube
and so that's what I'm doing right now
if I had to pick one social media
platform to brand myself to get my
message out there it would be to youtube
one because it connects to people better
or any people see your message on video
it's gonna resonate way more than just
seeing a tweet or a picture on Facebook
and the content lasts so much longer I'm
still getting use an engagement from
videos that I put up years ago I'm not
getting that on Twitter right if it's
over a day old it's gone people forget
about it so I would be all-in on YouTube
YouTube has gotten me sales it's got
many speaking opportunities has gotten
me newsletter subscribers has gotten me
a lot of momentum so that's the first
one second thing I'd be doing if I was
starting over from scratch is looking at
Alliance partners
alright the fastest way to grow is to
find people who are already connected to
your target audience and find a way to
partner with them so if I was trying to
build buzz about my website I would look
at who else is targeting my audience who
else is a has a popular website who else
has a popular blog who else has a
popular YouTube channel that I could
partner up with and do a guest video for
them or do a guest blog post for them if
you're looking at YouTube a service I
would recommend checking out that's
totally free it's called Fame bit FA m
bi t.com where it's basically YouTube
collaborators you can post your channel
and say hey here's my channel I'm
looking for collaborations in this genre
and other youtubers who have an audience
will submit proposals and you can do
guest posts guest videos on each other's
channel and so I've gotten a lot of new
subscribers to my channel by doing that
and given me more exposure so think
about who are
your target audience and how can you
partner up with them to reach their
audience and get them to introduce you
to them and the third thing is media
find media outlets who are again
targeting your target audience and
instead of trying to go up to your
customers one at a time at a time at a
time you can use the media to spread
your message to thousands or hundreds of
thousands or millions when I was first
starting up and this is what I would do
all over again I made a list of all the
media who covered small business
entrepreneurship because that was my
audience and every two weeks I'd read a
news story for them and every two weeks
I get picked up by at least one outlet
and so I was guests on radio shows on TV
shows I was in newspapers and magazines
I used a paid service called PR leads
comm and they you know send leads from
reporters who are looking for experts
and as a result I got into New York
Times I got into The Wall Street Journal
I got into Forbes and so I got picked up
a lot and again that helps you reach a
lot of critical mass really quickly so
that's what I would do tour if I was
starting out all over again brand new
from scratch I would go all-in on
YouTube find Alliance partners to
connect with and then use the media to
help spread my message and get people to
my website I like it too the calls I
have Tim on the line Tim where are you
from and how can I help
good morning I'm in Colorado all right
the program what's going on Thanks well
you know here's I'm getting ready to
launch a new consumer product and while
I was doing my research I found a guy on
LinkedIn who's like a real heavy hitter
in the business I'm gone for and just
out of the blue I just contacted him and
that started a month-long dialogue
between us and I can't afford his
services but I'm thinking of offering
him an equity stake in my company as an
enticement to to join me and I just want
to know what your feelings are on him
because this guy is I mean he's got
offices in London and Singapore and he
could be really helpful to me yeah so
this is a really big question you know
getting an equity partner is like
getting married it's is really important
if you get there
person it can really screw over your
company and it's great to look at their
skill sets at what they bring but you
also have to look on the values
perspective right like do you see eye to
eye with the type of person you are
right the things you believe in the
values that you share or don't share
because it's all great at the early
stage when you where there's nothing but
potential but when things go wrong
there's a lot of arguments and fights in
how you're going to deal with that with
an equity partner one thing I would
definitely look at is having a way to
have him earn in so is he interested in
equity have you brought this up where
this is just an idea that you're
thinking about yeah he's actually he's
offered because he really I found a real
specific niche market and and he was
like congratulations nobody's found that
so he's excited about the product we've
Skyped a few times so you know I
actually you know face to face it could
get a good read on him and and you know
so yeah he brings a lot to the table and
he is interested in an equity stake
because he likes the product so and like
I said he's you know he's very big in
the industry so I'm excited yeah I'm
more than willing and II on the face of
it
he said his contribution is he'll draw
up a business plan then he believes he
can bring more investors into into the
product so and it's great and it sounds
like you kind of already made up your
mind on it and now we're trying to
figure out how to reduce your risk no
what I would do is is structure
something where he earns in so he either
buys in and he's paying you cash or he's
earning in and he's bringing you
something so a business plan great but I
want to see him bring you customers I
want to see him bring you investors and
you can have milestones and I've done
this in the past with with other
businesses where you know I had a
superstar sales guy come in who wanted
to be you know head of sales and the
owner in the business I said okay great
you know when you get this much in sales
you get your first 5% of the company and
when we read you this much you get 10%
in this much 15 in this much 20 and that
was our cap so I don't know what you're
thinking about giving up but let him
earn in like make him show that
he is giving you value and real tangible
value besides just you know drawing up
plans and presentations if you think
it's in the form of customers or
investors or something else but
something that is giving an actual
practical value and write that into into
the shareholders agreement where you
know he will earn this equity when he
reaches these milestones like that
that's that's a good that's a good
thought
because here's when he came back to me
his charge if I had paid for his service
was $25,000 then if I had 25,000 I would
have spent it okay yeah and so how much
are you willing to give up with your
business for $25,000 right 25,000 it's a
lot of money but it's also not a lot of
money if you're thinking about where
this company will grow you know if
you're giving up a quarter of your
business for this that means your
company's only worth $100,000 you know
is that is that legit reasonable it's a
it's a tough decision but having him
earned in is your first step the next
thing that I want you to do you have a
corporation set up yes okay and you have
a shareholders agreement not yet I did
I'm the only registered it and I
mentally I don't have a board I'm just a
only guy in my LLC right now got it okay
what you want to make sure you have is a
shotgun clause and a piggyback clause
and you'll you'll need to you know you
could I guess we search it online I
would talk to a lawyer just to make sure
everything is ironed up perfectly but a
shotgun clause basically allows one
person to buy out another person so it
it in case you guys get to some kind of
disagreement and and there's an impact
and you can't get through it you can say
okay well I'm gonna buy you out at this
price or you get the bar me out at the
same valuation so it makes sure that you
can you can split if you need to all
right okay the other is a piggyback
clause which if you ever want to sell
the business for example he can't block
it he has to come along with it so I
don't know what your end goal is maybe
maybe you want to sell the Nestle or my
soft or whatever it is you know and he
may say no I don't want to sell as the
minority shareholder he can block
potential sale and so the piggyback
means you have to come along with it I
love those yeah I mean a simple talk
with the lawyer will help you identify
those issues and make sure those are
written in but that that helps protect
your risk right that helps protect you
from having this potential deadbeat
partner that's the worst case right you
have a deadbeat partner who's just
holding you back and it's not
contributing anything so that helps you
you know mitigate that risk where you
know if the upside goes well then you
have nothing to worry about everything
everybody's happy thank you all right
it's no problem good luck to him thank
you sir but great I'm for everybody
listening you know partnerships can be
great you can have a lot of success with
them but make sure you're bringing on
the right partner do your homework to
make sure you get the right values you
both believe in the same thing as well
as the vision and mission of the
business and then protect yourself have
them earning don't just give away equity
for free have them earn in and have the
shotgun claws and piggyback claws in
your agreement so that if anything goes
wrong you've protected your downside you
don't have a lot of risk going into it
it's it's scary and exciting all the
ones so Tim best of luck the next
question I got was from a YouTube viewer
called gabs who wrote in to say hi Evan
I'm planning to start a small business
process outsourcing business and my
friend has an established call center
office I'm planning to partner up with
them I got all the important things like
clients and everything he has a facility
that I will rent in the back office for
my campaign I want to know how much
percentage can I give him regarding my
gross sales thanks this is a great
question how much should you pay for
rent depending on your gross sales now
this depends on every industry every
industry is a little bit different you
know if you're in the retail clothing
business you're gonna have a high rent
it's gonna be a big part of your your
gross sales because you need foot
traffic so the rents can be expensive if
you're a legal services business then
it's not going to be as expensive right
because you don't need as much foot
traffic so you can uh you can afford to
get non retail space what I want you to
do is try to stay under ten
cent okay you want less than ten percent
of your sales to go to rent if you're
getting a lot higher than that it's
gonna be hard to stay in business
ideally you want to be in the five
percent range or less now that may take
a little bit of time as you build up
your business but what I would say is if
you're gonna partner with the sky don't
make it a fixed percentage because as
you grow a company the amount of rent
that you pay as a percentage of your
sales should go down right the amount of
rent that your paint should be constant
but the amount of sales that you're
making should be going up right so that
percentage should be decreasing so I
wouldn't give them a fixed percentage
right I would
I wouldn't say ten percent of my sales
goes to you every month because of rent
you're bringing a lot more to the table
and that's gonna cost you a lot more
money as it go down the road I would try
to figure out a set rate for how much
that rent would be I also think is this
really a partnership that you want if
you're bringing most of the stuff you're
bringing the important stuff right
you're bringing the the work you're
bringing in the clients he's just giving
you a space to do it in I wouldn't be
giving him a percentage of my business
that's not enough right you're that's
something that you can you can even
start from home if you wanted to right
he's not given enough to the business to
justify a partnership now if he's
bringing you clients if he's giving you
a lot more than just a location then you
can talk okay hopefully that helps I
want to get to the calls I have time for
one last caller who do I have on the
line Michelle Michelle where are you
from and how can I help
I'm from New Jersey and I have a
question I'm starting up an independent
consulting for health and fitness and I
wanted to know what is the most
effective means to reach potential
clients yeah this is tough because
you're in a super competitive industry
I'd be looking at two things one you
need to stand out right like what what
makes your fitness program better
different than everybody else because
there are so many people in that
business
what makes your program different
whether it's a training method whether
you're targeting a certain group you
know if you're targeting older men or
younger
women or whatever it is you need to have
a niche that you can go after that's
different from everybody else is there
anything you have in mind well actually
I'm working with a company but as an
independent consultant they they kind of
already have the product it's just my my
job to build my own independent business
through the company of you know
attracting people to come to the to my
website attracting people to come in and
want to buy the product under my website
that's how I make the Commission's as
also lots of people buying the products
for me and not through the company
directly so is it is it network
marketing affiliate marketing yeah yeah
okay so the first thing I would do there
then is do you use the product
absolutely
okay great well a lot of people don't so
that's that's good you got to start
building that personal brand and I start
thinking about showing how you use the
product and why it's so great most of
the people who are selling network
marketing affiliate marketing stuff they
use they just use the basic website that
the company gives them and they're
trying to drive traffic to that and they
usually have very few options of what
they can do where I'd love to see you
have your own site where you're sharing
how you're using it and the great
benefits that you are getting from using
that product you know you could be
sharing fitness tips alongside it your
workout routines along seinem whatever
it is how you're using and how people
can benefit from it and start building
yourself up as as an expert as a brand
in that industry and you just happen to
be selling XYZ product mm-hmm so have
you done a youtube video for example I
have not some of my students because I
am also full-time as a teacher so my
students have said you should make a
video and put it up and I'm like okay
how maybe they can help this is a good
start I'm thinking of asking them to
today they seem to have the idea to do
it yeah no you should what I would be
thinking about is what what are the
major benefits that you got from using
this product and then how can you make
that demonstrable right how can
show a video that highlights how you're
using a products and not just like not
just a sales pitch not just hey this
product is great
because that's why Z people can see
through that but letting your passion
for the product and how it's helped you
improve your life shine through with the
video and not just one video but a
series right you do one and every week
you forgot a new one coming out can help
to start build some traction and
momentum around what you're doing I like
that idea one video a week I like that
thank you yeah and if you have students
who can help and they're they're young
and tech-savvy and have the gear and you
know it's a great it's a great start the
other thing I would do is start thinking
about just like some of the previous
callers who can you partner with that
you can help make that connection so who
else like who's your target audience and
then who else is targeting that same
audience but with something else in your
local community and how can you partner
up with them because part of what you
have to do is also build your your
downline right yeah yeah and so you'll
actually typically make more from
building a downline than from selling it
yourself
and so it's starting by selling yourself
and then developing the system that then
you can give to other people and by you
learning how to do video you can show
other people how to do video as well and
give them the marketing engine to go out
and start selling cool I'm excited for
you I bet you know I'm observing all
this and it makes sense and I think
maybe my students are on track and now
that you're saying it it makes me want
to say okay I think this weekend I'm
gonna start by making a video and maybe
start with laying out all the clothes
that don't fit me no more and showing
everybody right now we've got to wrap up
the show but thank you for calling in
make it happen this weekend I love it
get that momentum going thank you for
calling in hey another great show in the
books thank you guys all for listening
thank you to my producers Christy and
Josh you guys Rock I will see you all
again in two weeks continue to believe
and we'll see you soon
if you want more entrepreneur goodness
check out the link to my newsletter
below see you there
you